let's talk about postal voting and why
it's such a big deal in the u.s
presidential election
a lot of voters want to mail in their
ballots because of the pandemic
to stay safe for the first time more
than three-quarters of americans will be
allowed to vote by mail
the president donald trump doesn't like
it mail ballots a very dangerous thing
for this country because they're
cheaters
he's being accused of trying to mess
with the election
to politicize and sabotage the postal
service in order to suppress votes
is dangerous so how does postal voting
work
can it really lead to voter fraud and
how might
all of this affect the presidential
election
[Music]
it's pretty astonishing really that
voting by mail
a pretty standard procedure around the
world is now one of the most
talked about issues in this presidential
race we'll get into all the politics in
a second
but first here are some basics
mail-in balloting in the u.s is pretty
popular it's for voters who can't get to
a polling station on election day
it's for the elderly the sick people who
live abroad
military personnel and people who just
prefer to vote that way
president trump mailed in his ballot in
2018
so did one quarter of all voters in the
last election
different states have different rules
there's what's called universal
mail voting where ballots are
automatically sent to everyone
and this year five states will run
mail-in-only elections including utah
solidly republican state but in most
states americans have to apply to get
what's called an
absentee ballot they have to contact
their local election authority
and normally they have to make the case
why they can't vote in person
but this year because of the pandemic
two-thirds of u.s states say they don't
require registered voters to give an
excuse
in order to get an absentee ballot
meaning
a lot more people will be able to vote
by mail this time around
so understandably there's concern that
there's going to be a strain on the
united states postal service
that could lead to delays and mistakes
because they do happen in 2016 states
rejected about one percent of ballots
for things like
late arrivals and missing signatures
with a lot more people voting by mail
this year i think it stands to reason
there are going to be
more of these problem ballots but there
are safeguards to try to reduce errors
and stop
fraud for example an absentee ballot can
only be sent to a person's registered
address
one envelope keeps the ballot private
and a second envelope is used to mail it
back
though most americans choose to drop off
the envelopes at government offices
voters also have to sign the ballot
envelope and election officials verify
the signature
they also come with barcodes so they can
be traced
all of those checks take extra time and
money
but this year the u.s postal service is
spending less
not more mailbox removed high-speed
sorting machines ripped out
overtime stopped for many
[Music]
there have been huge cuts in some states
it's already
led to delays it's nothing been in there
for the last two weeks
two weeks no bills no paper no nothing
the man behind those cuts is the new
postmaster general
who took charge in june louis de joy is
a businessman who was appointed by trump
to reform the postal service
and it is in trouble it's 160 billion
dollars in debt
that's mostly because back in 2006 a new
law
forced the post office to pre-pay
employees retirement and health care
benefits
75 years into the future add to that
things like people not mailing as much
as they used to
but trump's critics are still skeptical
of dejoy's appointment for a few reasons
he's personally given the republican
party and donald trump close to three
million dollars in donations since 2016.
that's concerning to us not only his
financial
relationships with the white house but
with private businesses
that are in competition with the united
states postal service
and the whole idea is it's not supposed
to be a politicized
agency he currently holds stock in
a company that has business dealings
with the us postal service
it does raise questions about ethical
conflicts president trump has appointed
a lot of people sort of loyal to him
what's unusual about the postal service
is that historically the postal service
has always promoted
people from within another concern is
about timing
why bring these cuts in now instituting
these sort of cost cutting exercises
in the middle of an election year
literally months before the election
looks very suspicious so why are people
suspicious
well for the last year president trump
has been attacking mail-in balloting
and he's making a lot of accusations
that ballots will be forged and even
illegally printed out and fraudulently
signed
that mail dropboxes make it possible for
people to vote multiple times
and that they aren't covet sanitized
that last one was actually flagged up by
twitter as potentially misleading
mail and ballots for both
[Music]
he's also openly said that universal
mail-in voting in his words
doesn't work out well for republicans
the democrats are doing it because in
theory it's good for them
there's sort of an instinctive belief
among many that making it easier to vote
in any way
will likely help democrats the
demographic groups that have the lowest
turnout rates in the united states
younger people
low-income people racial ethnic
minorities those are groups that tend to
vote for democrats
at the same time postal voting is also
used a lot by elderly voters
studies show they tend to skew
republican and trump is actually
encouraging
mail-in voting in florida which is home
to a lot of retirees
but it's a different story in nevada
trump is suing the state for changing
its rules so that all registered voters
get a ballot in the mail
here's the thing florida has a
republican governor
nevada's is a democrat it's why trump's
opponents feel this is all deeply
political
okay so what about these allegations of
possible corruption
well fraud is rare but it does happen
the washington post did an analysis of
recent elections in
three vote-by-mail states they found 372
possible cases of double voting or
voting on behalf of people who died
that was out of more than 14 million
mail-in ballots
that's a minuscule percentage the most
recent example of fraud was in 2018
involving a staff member of north
carolina's republican congressman mark
harris
harris's political strategist mccray
dallas accused of tampering with more
than 500
absentee ballots to help harris win so
while the politicians argue about the
odds of a rigged election
plenty of people are worried that this
will all just end up a giant mess and
that's mainly because
of those budget cuts to the postal
service
dejoy says he's paused them but some
think the damage has already been done
he was even called in by a congressional
committee to reassure americans that the
postal system can handle all those votes
the postal service is fully capable and
committed to delivering the nation's
election mail
securely and on time many democrats
though
aren't convinced the house of
representatives which is controlled by
the democrats
passed an emergency bill to give 25
billion dollars to the post office
more than two dozen republicans voted
for it the bill
is passed but the republican-controlled
senate
hasn't passed the bill anybody who wants
to give money to the post office
you might as well just put it into a big
pile on your front lawn and burn it you
can't run a business with 80
of your costs being labor but politics
aside
actually most americans democrats and
republicans
hold up the postal service as an
important public institution
and right now it's under a lot of
pressure it's got to help deliver this
election
in the middle of a pandemic and delays
are likely
some states will still be counting votes
that arrive after election day
so let's be clear we probably can't
expect to have a winner straight away
and any hiccups could be used by both
presidential candidates to contest the
result
and they say they're ready for a fight
the only way they can take this
election away from us is if this is a
rigged election
he knows that on the legit it'd be hard
for him to win
so he wants to put obstacles of
participation but we do not
agonize we organize this year
more than ever americans are relying on
the u.s postal service to help
choose their next president but this
whole drama has created doubt
in a system many have trusted they need
it to work
because this election is expected to be
a close one
that was just one of a series of
explainers we've been working on to help
us
all understand the issues around the us
election so to keep up with
all our upcoming episodes i recommend
subscribing to al jazeera wherever
you're watching this video
i'll see you next week
[Music]
you